good morning
my name is adrian diggs i'm bc's
minister of health i'm
speaking to you this morning from the
territory of the muskram of the squamish
of the slave of tooth first nations
honored to be here on their lands i'm
joined in victoria by dr bonnie henry
speaking from the territories of the la
cuangan speaking people the slangies and
the esquimalt first nations this is our
covenant 19 briefing for friday january
the 21st and with that is my honor to
introduce dr bonnie henry
thank you very much update i'm going to
uh
begin by sharing a few slides giving
some information that we have been
pulling together around people who are
in hospital and help us understand who
is more likely to end up with severe
enough illness that they require
hospitalization
we continue to see a decrease in a
slowdown in new cases in british
columbia and as of the last few days
tentatively
a slowing down in hospital admissions
however they do continue to be
high relative to what we have seen
throughout this pandemic
so to give you a sense of
hospitalization risk based
hospital in british columbia and this is
a a measure that we've been trying to
understand who is in our hospitals
how has it changed during this period
with omicron being the predominant
strain that we're seeing circulating and
who is at risk and there's a number of
reasons for this
one is so that we can provide that extra
advice to people about who needs to be
tested who needs to take extra
precautions in the community but also so
that we know that it can guide who has
access to
the treatments that are becoming
available
here in bc including pax lavid which we
received and we'll be receiving as well
as satrovamab which is a monoclonal
antibody that is used for some people as
well
so what we did and kudos to our analysis
team we looked at 606 people who were
hospitalized out of a little over 4 49
000 confirmed covet 19 cases between
december 14th and january 6th and we
analyzed what were the risk factors
underlying people's need for admission
to hospital and during this period of
time the hospitalization rate was
unconfirmed cases during this period was
1.2 percent so that is uh is uh very
similar to what we presented in the
modeling presentation a week ago
and it shows that it is a dramatic
decrease from what we saw or with the
delta wave that we were managing between
september and october
so what puts someone at risk greater
risk for covet 19 hospitalization now
and it should be said this is similar to
what we have seen across the entire
pandemic the single most important risk
factor for having severe illness with
covet 19 that requires hospitalization
is age
and people who are aged 80 and over are
28 times more likely to be hospitalized
if they get infected with covet 19
controlling for every other risk factor
so this is really really important once
again we know that it is our seniors and
elders who are most at risk in the
community in long-term care homes and
across the board and really we see that
major increase after age 70.
we also see an increase
in risk of hospitalization for people
who have immune compromising conditions
and we have a few of those on here if
you're a transplant recipient for
example
people who have diabetes respiratory
illness heart conditions and as we have
found out through the studies that have
been led by investigators here in bc
that pregnancy is also a risk for having
more severe illness than ending up in
hospital
on the positive side we see across the
board again
that vaccination is highly highly
protective and it reduces your risk by
nine times if you control for all of
these other factors to have your your
booster dose and that is uh that's
encouraging it reminds us that right now
being vaccinated not only reduces your
risk of of being infected although it's
not 100
for sure but when you get that third
booster dose it does increase your your
risk or decrease your risk of being
affected but dramatically decreases your
risk of needing hospitalization
if we look at um we divide things out by
um
by risk
categories oops
and we we look at people who have
combinations of risk factors that make
them at a very high risk we see that
between the period of september and
october and december and january so
comparing what was predominantly delta
to now what's predominantly omicron that
regardless of the risk category there's
a lower rate of hospitalization right
now so that's important that tells us
that even those at very high risk have a
much lower rate hospitalization rate now
than what we were seeing in the fall and
this is a combination of factors
including
the fact that
most people especially in the very high
risk categories are vaccinated right now
but also it does reflect that omicron is
causing less severe illness in most
people the challenge of course that we
have is that omicron is infecting many
more people so this lower
hospitalization rate still translates
translates into large numbers of people
requiring hospital care and we're seeing
that impact in our hospitals right now
the other thing that we can look at is
putting this together
by risk by age group so putting the how
many people in each age category fit
into the high medium low or very low
risk age groups and you can risk
categories and as you can see for people
under age 20 the vast majority of that
population
is a very low risk with a small
proportion at about a low risk and an
even smaller proportion with a medium
risk but as we go up in age the
proportion of people in that age
category who have those higher risk
factors for ending up in hospital goes
up so again it's another way of looking
at who are more likely to end up in
hospital regardless of all the important
things that we put in place to
like vaccination and who needs to take
extra precautions be extra careful about
what they're doing in the community
about the measures that they're taking
as uh omicron is spreading widely right
now
so putting all this together it helps us
get what we call a heat map or a whole
a way of looking at
our risk based on age based on our
our sex because we know that has some
implications we know that
since the beginning of this pandemic men
with covid are more likely to be have
more severe illness and be admitted to
hospital than women for a variety of
reasons but it also helps us break it
down by vaccination and really
what you can see across the board is
once you have two doses of vaccine and
particularly as we get older three doses
of vaccine are highly protective at
keeping people out of hospital and those
people right now who are most at risk
who are most likely to end up in
hospital if you get infected with covet
are people who do not have any vaccines
so a combination of things that we are
looking at this um supports the
information that we provided through the
the modeling that was done last week and
it really looks at who is in our
hospital who's at risk of ending up in
hospital with this wave that we are all
going through right now and that tells
us what are the things that we can do
and who do we need to focus on to
prevent hospitalizations and severe
illness putting this all together and so
i i know this is difficult to see on the
screen but it will be available on the
bccdc website and i encourage people to
have a look
if we look at
young people who are vaccinated and even
older people who are vaccinated with
three doses your risk of having severe
enough illness that you need
hospitalization is negligible it's under
one percent so that's important that's
really good news and even two doses
reduces your risk substantially but if
you are even younger
and you don't have vaccine on board your
chances of requiring a getting more
severe illness go up dramatically
particularly if you have any of the
underlying at-risk conditions that make
it more likely
so this gives us a sense
of what is going on in terms of the
people who are ending up in hospital
right now
as we know this is a rapidly evolving
situation with omicron and i know that
when public health guidance changes the
changes raise a lot of questions and
concerns
we all ask ourselves with the new or
eased restrictions what does this mean
to me and my family and what do i need
to be doing differently as we move
through this new and different wave of
the pandemic so i want to spend a little
bit of time talking about this i have
talked about some of the
changes we have in testing and on
isolation but i think we need to go back
to the basic principles the omicron
variant is different
so we have adapted how we manage this
situation
while most people now will not need
testing for covet 19
it is important that we all have the
information we need about what measures
we can take to prevent spread of illness
and to manage when we are exposed or get
sick ourselves
even with omicron spreading most people
being tested for covet 19 don't have it
yes we have our highest test positivity
rates ever and it's in the 20 percent uh
to thirty percent range but that means
that seventy percent of people with
symptoms who are being tested don't have
covet 19. so we need to put that in
context as well
this change aligns with the
evidence-based communicable disease
principles that we follow when we manage
in public health when we're managing any
respiratory communicable disease
and from the very beginning contact
tracing is a public health intervention
that is well suited and applied to some
communicable diseases and not others
disease characteristics that make
contact tracing effective are things
like having a longer incubation period
because you have to have time to find
people after somebody's been tested
low infectiousness as we've seen as this
uh with covent for example as it becomes
more and more infectious it's much more
challenging to find people with contact
tracing
and we also need
measures effective measures that
contacts can take to prevent infection
for themselves or to others and if we
look at measles for example that has a
two to three week incubation period we
have time to find somebody we can
provide them with vaccination for
example that can protect them from
developing symptoms themselves
other diseases are hepatitis for example
where again you can provide an
intervention that will prevent
transmission
these disease characteristics make it
possible to identify and reach a high
proportion of contacts who can then take
measures to protect themselves or others
and early on in this pandemic even up
until the delta wave we were able to
find most people in that five to seven
day incubation period and have them
isolate so that they wouldn't be a risk
to others
but we now have a couple of things that
have changed one this is highly
infectious now and it has a shorter
incubation period and many people will
have mild or asymptomatic infections and
not even realize that they are infected
and we have new and better interventions
including vaccines and now some
treatments so with the emergence of
these more transmissible variants with
shorter incubation periods
covet 19 is no longer an infection for
which contact tracing is an effective
intervention
we now need to shift our management and
think about the things that we can do
across the board to prevent transmission
and to prevent ourselves from being
exposed
the number one most important one of
course is vaccination
self-management
so making sure we're managing our own
symptoms
and testing of those who are eligible
for treatment and
for a testing of people who are living
or working in higher risk settings
that's the change that we've been making
over this past few weeks as we've
learned more and more about omicron and
how it is different from the other
strains of of covet that we've see of
sarsko v2 that we've seen
i absolutely recognize this as a shift
and it means we have to change our way
of thinking that we have been working on
so intently together for the last two
years
but we are all familiar with these new
measures they're much more like how we
manage other respiratory illnesses even
influenza or
rsv or enteroviruses that cause the
common cold
we cannot eliminate all risk and i think
that's something that we we need to
understand and accept as this virus has
changed and has become part of what we
will be living with for years to come
but we can use
all of the layers of protection to keep
our workplaces our schools our
healthcare and other activities running
as safely as possible
so at this time everyone all of us needs
to routinely check ourselves every day
self-monitor and if we have symptoms
that might be covered that might be
influenza that might be a cold we need
to stay home till we feel better
and there are some caveats to that which
i'll go through
right now with the level of transmission
in our communities we all need to assume
that we have been in contact with
somebody with the virus
and what does that mean for our daily
activities
first when it comes to what we have been
doing
following public health guidance we need
to keep doing that
what that means getting vaccinated
absolutely there is incontrovertible
evidence and i've shown you some of it
today that vaccination
not only stops reduces your risk of
transmission doesn't eliminate it but it
reduces it and it reduces your risk of
passing it on to others
but most importantly it dramatically
decreases your risk of having severe
enough illness that you end up in
hospital
washing our hands regularly wearing good
quality masks when we're in indoor
settings keeping our groups small
because we are still in this wave
and
i'm being extra cautious if you're at
higher risk and i've explained some of
the things that make people at higher
risk
in addition to following the public
health guidance
things like having our vaccine card
program so that we mitigate those risks
and
we provide extra protection for those
who are more risk of having severe
illness which includes
people who are not yet protected through
vaccination that's an extra layer of
protection
second as long as we are feeling well in
this new context we can and must
continue going to work going to school
and socializing safely in our small
groups
we are all close contacts of somebody
with the virus so we absolutely need to
pay attention to how we are feeling and
making sure that we have a very low
threshold for staying away and waiting
for another day if we're feeling unwell
we but we don't need to isolate if a
friend or family member has
knows that they have covet because there
are many more people who've not been
tested who may have it as well and we
need to treat this
across the board as if we've been
exposed
so the next question is what happens if
you or family member starts to feel
unwell
the rule of thumb and what we all need
to pay attention to right now is if
you're feeling unwell stay away from
others and return to northern normal
activities when you're feeling better
particularly if you have a fever you
need to stay home and stay away from
others
but if you have a mild illness like a
sore throat or the sniffles stay home
and if you feel better the next day then
you can go back to school or work or
child care this applies to children in
daycare or in school as well as with
adults
we know the covet 19 transmission is
widespread but there are also other
respiratory illnesses that are
circulating right now and these measures
apply to them all
so how do you know if you have covet 19
or need to get tested
a starting point to answer that question
is the newly updated
bccdc symptom checker
it outlines the symptoms of covet 19 and
it helps let you know if you are in one
of those risk categories
that should be booking a test
otherwise continue to follow that path
of staying home until you are feeling
better if the symptom checker advises
you to get tested then you should
continue to limit your interactions with
others and get tested as soon as
possible and we follow the requirements
for self-isolation and i'll talk to
those in a minute
so these are the requirements for
unvaccinated adults if you test positive
for covid we know that the risk of
having longer-lasting more severe
illness is higher so you must
self-isolate for 10 days
for people who are vaccinated and for
children
5 days
is the important period of time if you
know you're covet positive of course
with all guidance there are always
exceptions if you are clinically
extremely vulnerable the conditions that
are more likely to to make you
have more severe illness if you're
immune compromised such as people going
through cancer treatments or other
treatments that affect your immune
system or have organ transplants or you
are over age 70
then you are likely to need a test you
should get tested right away so you can
be access treatment if that is needed
if you are having any other
medical conditions that make it
difficulty breathing or have concerns
about chest pain please seek medical
attention immediately
so i know we get asked and i've been
asked as i've talked about this a number
of times why is isolation different for
unvaccinated adults and children who
test positive
so we know that vaccination and we've
seen more and more evidence of this
helps us clear the virus faster and it's
been shown to reduce transmission with
delta and with previous variants and we
have some
data now out of copenhagen that shows
that particularly with the booster dose
but with two doses of vaccine you also
reduce transmission in the family
and therefore vaccination allows for a
shorter minimum isolation period it
doesn't mean that it eliminates that
risk and we've seen that
people who have infected with omacron
even with mild illness can
shed for up to 10 days like we see with
other variants but that risk is reduced
and it goes down quite dramatically
after about day three to five so we are
mitigating that risk that's why we say
it's important to continue to do those
other things like wearing a mask when
you're around other people following the
covet safety plans that you have in your
workplace following the plans that are
in place in child care or in schools
children are much lower risk of severe
illness thankfully and that's one of the
bright lights on this pandemic
and there is increasing evidence that
the social isolation can impact
children's development by limiting their
opportunities for interaction with
others and a shorter isolation period
enables
us to to have that other important
getting back to societal function by
allowing parents and caregivers to
return to work including essential
workers
vaccinating all of those who are
eligible around children is a much more
effective intervention than isolating
children so we have a different
measure for making sure that we support
children to getting back to their
important activities as soon as possible
with the increase in transmission our
communities we've also seen increases in
cases and outbreaks in long-term care
and assisted living both amongst
residents and staff
and for family members for people who
work and and operate in long-term care
and for our public health team i know
this is very concerning and our focus
continues to be to protect our elders
and seniors who we know and we've seen
the data are more vulnerable to severe
illness but also to balance that with
ensuring our seniors have the care and
the support they need
and we know that that has changed that
balance is changing as we've had
the high uptake of booster doses both in
staff and in residence in long-term care
and as we've seen much milder illness in
many cases with omicron so there is
changes that we're making and how we
support
long-term care homes and residents and
staff and long-term care as we're going
through this transition period as well
and we want to make sure that we're
achieving this balance recognizing
that depending on vaccination and
booster doses
um that illness is has changed and we
don't necessarily need all the same
restrictions that we had in place with
the some more with more severe um
strains of of
of covet 19.
i have spoken many times over the last
two years or how we're all in the same
storm but we are all in different boats
and it is challenging when change is
happening very quickly and when it's
hard to keep up with what that means
we're all connected however and our
experiences are unique but our
challenges in getting through this
pandemic together
are the same
getting through this pandemic is far
about far more than public health orders
it's about all of us
taking care of ourselves our families
our communities doing our part every day
and we know the things that are working
we know that there are changes and we're
adapting and adjusting to those changes
we're working hard to get through this
surge and i want to thank everybody in
bc for their efforts i know it has been
more challenging than ever as things
have changed over this last month
and we have more distance to go
we are hopefully at a place where we are
getting through this wave again and
we'll be in a better place very soon
and we will see this through together
thank you
[Applause]
very much dr henry and uh i wanted to
just say
just say give a few updates on the
impact of sickness on our healthcare
workers and healthcare system
and on rapid tests i did want to note
and
that the
charts presented by dr henry today will
be posted on the bccdc website on the
government website on social media i
encourage people when they are
to refer to them because you will see
yourself but also the ones you love in
these charts
and
just as an example i can see myself in
these charts and just explain to you
what vaccination
means for me in the present context and
people in my circumstances i'm in my 50s
and i have type 1 diabetes and if you
look at this chart it tells you
that compared to being if i were
unvaccinated my risk of hospitalization
is a staggering eight times higher
than my current circumstance which is
i've been triple vaxxed i've received
three vaccinations and the booster dose
without the booster dose my risk of
hospitalization would be twice as high
and this is true for
people in high-risk categories and i
want to make this point to everyone we
emphasized at every stage of our
vaccination program this issue of risk
older people got vaccinated before
younger people those who are clinically
vulnerable
such as myself in this case got
vaccinated somewhat before those who
weren't and that has been true in the
booster dose campaign that has been the
emphasis of that campaign
such that of those eligible over 70
about 85 percent of people have now been
vaccinated
of those who are clinically vulnerable
in types in groups one and two that's
not me but groups one and two they're
about 85 percent vaccinated but it does
mean that in those categories people who
are have been twice vaccinated but are
there are tens of thousands of people
still in bc who've been invited to be
vaccinated who are clinically vulnerable
we're over 70 or over 65 or over 60 with
higher levels of risk who have not yet
booked their appointments and i
encourage you to do so today received
your invitation you haven't booked your
appointments in those cases and this
chart read this chart
and then book your vaccination today
and for whatever reason if you're you're
one of the people in the categories and
it's a smaller group because 93 percent
of those over 70 receive their first
dose of 91 receive their second dose but
if you're in that seven percent or if
you're in that nine percent who hasn't
been vaccinated
get vaccinated today
and if you are looking for a first and
second dose in general you should be
able to do that through this weekend so
i i suggest to everybody that they take
this information about themselves but
also the ones they love and act
accordingly which is following public
health guidance
following public health orders
protecting one another in what is a
difficult time in a difficult storm and
protecting our health care workers and
health care
just want to update you with respect to
rapid tests and
where we are today
after
and how that changed in the last three
days
at the end of day yesterday bc had
received 5 million
958
820 rapid tests to date and deployed
three million eight hundred and sixty
thousand sixty four of these tests to
key strategic areas
of the five million nine five point nine
million tests received more than a
million a million and ninety nine
thousand were received over the last
four days that's since monday january
17th
that leaves a current inventory of two
million and ninety eight thousand tests
including the million we just received
558 000 of the current inventory are not
suitable for deployment for take away
our personal use they require special
equipment administration by trained
health care professionals etc they can't
be broken down so those are going to be
continued to be used by medical health
officers to manage clusters and
outbreaks that leaves 1.5 1 million for
539 820 tests that are suitable for
self-administered use
this week we will be delivering
we will be delivering and allocating
those tests as follows 150 000 to
replenish supplied acute care health
acute health care facilities for testing
of symptomatic health care workers
192 400 for repackaging and distribution
to testing sites across bc to replenish
their supply and i received some
questions about that yesterday 115 000
more tests are being prepared to support
testing in the k-12
education sector that's the total to
date of 345 000.
236 998 more tests for use by businesses
and organizations as part of the point
of care screening program
and long-term care and assisted living
sites will continue to receive
additional inventory to replenish their
supply
the remainder and new supply arriving
the next few days will be allocated in
the days in the days ahead for to
long-term care acute care hospitals for
staff testing sites businesses k-12 and
post secondary and just to put it in
context because we have a lot of talk
about numbers all the time
that we expect to receive
and this is information is from the
federal government between now in the
middle of february 15 million
719 920 tests
i wanted to also
take the opportunity to update you uh on
the impact of illness on health care
workers and our health care system i
want to again express my thanks to
healthcare workers to our incredible
teams of healthcare professionals in
public health across the province who
are working tirelessly day and night to
get us through the pandemic
health authorities have closely
monitored sickness levels across across
health services especially in hospitals
long-term care and home support so i
want to bring you some up-to-date
numbers
which show i would say an improving
situation but one that is still a
significant challenge from january 17th
to three days from january 17th through
19th at least 7 952 workers called in
sick
this includes 1601 in vancouver coastal
2325 and fraser health
1919 in interior health
1947 in island health
948 in northern health
1096 in the provincial health services
authority and 441 in providence health
care just to be clear this is not all
covered 19. illness could be due to
cover 19 or something else
we continue to have mitigation plans in
place to deliver the healthcare british
colombians need while also keeping our
communities as safe and healthy as we
can just to put it in context and when i
talk about an improving situation if you
look at the period from january 10th to
12th which i reported at last friday's
regular briefing
there were 11 000 and 10
health care
workers sick in that period from january
10th to 12th the equivalent period again
no statutory holidays involved here
january 17th to 19th that number is
7952 which is significantly less about a
quarter less a little over a quarter
less than it was which is a significant
reduction although significantly above
as well
what is expected in normal times i'm
committed we're committed to restoring
all services that have been interrupted
in the in the weeks to come just want to
give you an update on some of those
services
so you know where we are
since
since
the announcements the information
bulletins and the briefings from health
30 ceos on tuesday a number of changes
have occurred as you've seen from the
daily information critical care demand
and fraser health has increased in
response to this fraser health has
operationalized an additional 10
critical care beds to ensure those
patients needing the most care have
access to it staff have been redeployed
to support this but not for there have
no been no further service reductions in
fraser health
next week island health is resuming some
non-urgent and ambulatory
care at community hospitals in the
region and in vermeer which we reported
on on tuesday
in interior health inpatient services
will remain open previously there was a
plan to stabilize those services to
support
the emergency department so
we continue to have these plans in place
and actions have been taken and in the
last week there has been amazing work by
health care workers in bc we're doing
close to 60 000 vaccinations a day the
vast majority of those
being booster doses we've done
in uh since the beginning of the booster
jokes campaign 1 million 750 000 booster
doses priorized to those at the greatest
risk
for severe illness which is i think an
extraordinary achievement and that is of
course increasing significantly every
day we're deploying more rapid tests
than ever before our health care workers
are treating more patients in our
hospitals 9 400
was the patient census across acute care
yesterday in short there is an enormous
amount to be proud of in our health care
system and it's our absolute intention
to restore all services as soon as
possible the services that we are
delaying currently to support core
services to our health care system that
will happen and in the meantime
the best thing all of us can do
is get vaccinated get your first shot
get your second shot get your booster
shot as soon as you're eligible
the vaccine remains our best defense the
evidence today shows that again as every
piece of evidence has shown it from the
beginning of the pandemic it saves lives
every day these vaccines
earlier this week i reported on
non-urgent scheduled surgeries that have
been postponed because of covet it's a
significant number
and the postponements have a significant
effect on all those whose surgeries
aren't occurring as planned right now
to those patients and to their families
and friends who provide them with
comfort care and support i would hope
that as they go into this weekend they
know this because this is also the
reality of our patients of our pandemic
patients whose surgeries are postponed
are never forgotten
patients whose surgeries are postponed
receive will receive a call to rebook
their surgeries patients whose surgeries
are postponed will get their surgeries
we made that commitment and we will
deliver on that commitment as we have
done earlier in the pandemic
so as al as the rest of us go into the
weekend i would hope that all of us
would understand just what surgery post
moments mean to those patients
and understand the ability we have
to reduce their anxiety by exercising
the control we have to stop kovid's
rapid spread and reduce the negative
impact it is having on our hospitals and
providers so let's make this another
weekend where we all continue to do our
part by doing the job so many other so
many are counting on us to do put covet
in its place and slow its current surge
have a safe weekend everyone will see of
course uh
at the briefing in the coming week and
with that i'm happy to take your
questions or we're happy to take your
questions reminder to everybody on the
phone line please press star one to
enter the queue
first question today is from
pennydaflowctv
thank you very much dr henry i just
wanted to start with you what is your
goal right now
in terms of what obviously we want to
our goals have not changed our goals are
to reduce serious illness and death so
morbidity and mortality
from the pandemic it's to preserve our
health care system so everybody whether
it's from covet or
needs care for other reasons are able to
access the care they need
and thirdly to minimize societal
disruptions so that we're minimizing
those negative consequences of any of
the measures that we're taking to manage
the pandemic that has not changed
penny do you have a follow-up
i do
because dr henry you keep talking about
this being a transition period but in a
really short amount of time you've
sliced slashed isolation guidelines both
in community and acute care
people who show up for testing now are
being turned away even if they have
symptoms because they're told they're
not in a high risk category or a
healthcare worker so it looks like
you've more or less given up on trying
to control covet and completely switch
to endemic mode over just a few days
even though our hospitals are still full
and the staff are barely holding on so
i'd like to know how you've come to the
decision to go to endemic mode now yeah
so that is not correct we are clearly
not in a place where it's endemic right
now what we are doing is adjusting to
the changes that we've seen
from the new variant it's what we're
dealing with right now and it tells us
with the shorter incubation period and
you know i talked about this a number of
times over this past month this
surprised us it came out of of
places where there was still a lot of
transmission
of the virus and this virus continues to
be persistent
to be changing and to to cause different
patterns of illness and i talked about
having to put together the pieces of the
puzzle to understand
how this virus strain was affecting us
and what we have seen is that the
measures that we were using to help
manage in other strains of the virus
particularly delta which was more
infectious and more severe but still had
that longer incubation period some of
those things that we were doing are no
longer effective now and that's the
parameters of the virus have changed so
we need to adapt to it which means we
need to adapt how we
take the the approach that we have
across the
across the board so because we have a
shorter incubation period because um the
vaccination is not a hundred percent
protective against infection
we needed to really look at you know who
is most at risk now who is
more likely to end up in hospital how do
we preserve our health care system how
do we reduce
serious illness and deaths continuously
so it is adapting to the the situation
we're in and we've had a number of
different orders we've gone back to our
coveted safety plans we've put in place
some restrictions on gatherings so this
is clearly not where we want to be
further
when we're living with this virus in an
endemic state
but i do believe that we will be moving
towards that and one of the things that
has changed is the level of exposure
that we've all had now to covet because
of this new strain and how it's moving
through our communities but i can't say
enough how important the measures that
we have in place so we have these
effective things now like vaccination
and it is showing how important it is
that vaccination does allow us to
minimize those disruptions on society as
we're continuing to have the
restrictions in place that we need to
get us through this place and you know
it's not my choice that this virus is
causing more illness in healthcare
workers you know it's a reality and so
we're talking about how do we manage
with the reality that this virus is
causing more uh illness and more people
to be off work in healthcare but in
other sectors as well from illness so it
really is
my job to raise that as this is one of
the key things that we have to deal with
in this phase of the pandemic and we're
not yet in an endemic state and we have
additional measures in place but we all
need to go back to the basics as well
because the things that we're doing to
prevent us from getting infected and to
prevent us from passing it on to others
are incredibly important right now
next question is from richard sussman
global news
dr henry i know this will be jarring for
a lot of people to hear the sort of
shifts today and i know you've been
alluding to this for a while but it's
different than what we're seeing in
other jurisdictions and i know when
you're asked jurisdictional questions
you say we're all dealing with this
differently but dr tam is speaking about
how symptoms can last for 10 days we end
isolation periods after five days other
jurisdictions aren't going as far as
saying close contacts don't have to
isolate at all so can you explain what
science we are looking at here that
makes our policies different than what
we are seeing in other jurisdictions
yeah so uh what dr tam says and i talked
to that again today but yes symptoms can
last for longer than 10 days and
symptoms can
people can transmit but your risk of
transmitting goes down after five to six
days and we have seen that with this
strain um so yes uh and what she was
referring to is a study that showed that
it was down to about 15 percent risk and
so what we are doing is with the reality
that we have here and this is something
that we have discussed across the
country with my colleagues and
the chief medical officers of health
we've been meeting with the lab
scientists with the modelers with others
to try and understand how do we best
manage this and so what we're looking at
here is what we're seeing and i
presented the data on people in hospital
we presented some of the data last week
on on who we're seeing getting sick and
how long they're getting sick and what
the incubation period is that we're
seeing so we're trying to mitigate that
risk of causing more harm
by healthcare workers not being in at
work at a period of time when they're
fully vaccinated and having mild illness
that's not lasting very long so we have
to balance those things and deal with
what we have here and i will say that
there is consistency across most of what
we're doing across the country and yes
some people are taking a a
and it depends a little bit on what
they're seeing as i've as i've said
where they're seeing outbreaks happen
where they're seeing more severe illness
happen and we're dealing with slightly
different proportions of of omicron
versus delta and people who are
hospitalized and in outbreaks so it is a
bit varied um i look at my colleagues in
prince edward island a place that's
my home and you know this is the first
wave that they've been through so there
is a much higher level of concern about
how to manage it
we have been through this we have we
have things in place we have coveted
safety plans in place that they don't
have necessarily in other settings
richard do you have a follow up
sergeant you mentioned long-term care
there as well i think a lot with loved
ones in the facility are hoping for and
waiting for new updated guidelines
around visitation you know when should
we expect to see
those new guidelines around long-term
care and just briefly can you speak to
me about what happened at the bcc dc
this week and why on tuesday the updated
guidelines saying unvaccinated people
could uh only have to isolate for five
days then on wednesday went back to 10
days yeah that
these were ongoing discussions that we
were having i i and i just mentioned
this in my last discussion these are
moving targets as we're learning more
and it was a misunderstanding and
when i recognized that that was posted
and we we changed it
i think our challenge was we changed it
without letting people know that it was
that it was a
mistake and the posting in the first
place um
these are things that are changing
really rapidly and to be frank
my staff are tired we've been
working on this for a long time and we
are also being affected by the fact that
lots of people are off sick right now so
it was a administrative challenge and an
error on our part um that we corrected
as soon as we did and it's my
responsibility to communicate that
better and i'll do that in the future
next question is from cole schissler
black press
dr bonnie henry at your last press
conference you said there's a narrative
that omicron is mild and cautioned that
one in 10 people have symptoms for 12
weeks or longer but you've said numerous
times even today that omicron is milder
for most people so is it a narrative or
is it a scientific fact and do you take
any responsibility for that narrative
given your past statements and policy
changes based on omicron being milder
yeah so i i think i have tried to
expunge the world world word mild from
my lexicon because it means different
things to different people so i was
trying to make the point and there is a
narrative that i don't believe i've
tried not to contribute to that we
should just abandon all restrictions we
should not be doing anything we should
just
let it go because it's mild and
who cares and so i do not subscribe to
that narrative and i think it's
important to recognize and we show that
again today that there are some people
who are at higher risk and we all have a
responsibility to try and minimize our
risk to them
by doing the things that help protect us
and protect others so it really i guess
i'm trying to find that
that balance of saying
yes it is
it is not causing as much severe illness
particularly in people who are
vaccinated
so that's the really important thing and
a lot of people who particularly if
you've had your third dose
younger people
are not having severe enough illness to
end up in hospital but it isn't is not
an innocuous illness
it is making people feel very unwell
some of them for a longer period of time
so i'm trying to find the balance
between that
over to you minister dicks
just to say this that
just to say this that uh
dr henry said today uh what the facts
are
which is that
on in an individual case
omicron has been less severe but there
are significantly more individual cases
which presents very significant problems
for lots of people and that's why
since the omicron variant of concern
came on the scene there were public
health orders on january 20th on the
23rd
on the 29th on the 31st another last
week with respect to covet safety plans
for businesses public health orders in
place with in all those respects to
respond to this
and we have seen and we are seeing
some decline
in test positivity although
it is still extremely high so those are
the actions taken in addition
we are doing at a time when there's a
lot of pressure on the healthcare system
that everyone acknowledges
a massive number
of uh vaccinations every week in booster
dose vaccinations such that 85 percent
of people the most vulnerable category
people over 70 who are eligible got
their their second and their third doses
their booster doses
earlier before that we'd priorize people
who were clinically vulnerable on
december 21st we put in place
our rapid test plan our new rapid test
plan
which
follows on the one from march of uh of
2021
in that period we've been providing more
care and preparing our hospital system
for the impact of omicron on healthcare
workers and those steps have been taken
were prepared and announced before
christmas especially with respect to
non-urgent scheduled surgeries and our
healthcare teams are putting them in
place so we can
continue to provide the extraordinary
service including yesterday 9400 people
in acute care so there has been these
are actions
that that have been i think allowed
people to see in those actions what they
need to do and that's been happening as
well that dr henry and her team have led
and the ministry of health myself and
others have led as well
and that reflects i think their ex their
extraordinary commitment and the
commitment of people and i have to say
that when i travel around bc when i go
to the grocery stores i did yesterday
evening everyone everyone
is wearing their mask i have not seen
someone in a grocery store in months
without a mask on
and that shows the public the effect of
the public health order that was put in
place by dr henry so
i i think that
what we try and do and what dr henry has
done with more detailed information here
about the risk of hospitalization
has been
followed through on specific by specific
actions in every area to help people
deal with a real public health challenge
that is more severe in other parts of
canada the omicron variant of concern
but is really of
of
had a similar effect on countries around
the world and i'm very very proud
of our public health teams and uh and dr
henry's leadership and i think british
columbians are as well
called do you have a follow-up
uh yeah this might be a better question
for minister dix um but there were
reports that a new policy from fraser
health says uh patients who are positive
with covid uh may be able to share rooms
with fully vaccinated patients who do
not have covet
can you explain the rationale behind
that decision and is are similar
policies on the way for other health
authorities across pieces
[Music]
really is about maximizing our ability
to provide care to people so uh as we
have presented and again today but uh
primarily last week we've been looking
at how many people are admitted to
hospital uh where their test on
admission
is positive so it's an incidental
finding it's not the reason for being in
hospital and they don't have
respiratory illness related to covid and
in those cases being able to maximize
the use of of space if needed
with additional precautions in place as
we would for
people admitted with other respiratory
illnesses
so that is an infection prevention and
control team decision made at uh at a
hospital by hospital and actually room
by room and word by ward basis
depending on the needs in that facility
dr henry made this point uh dr henry
made this point uh last week has did i
that the challenge of having more people
in a hospital is the challenge of
cohorting everybody is much more
difficult and so that's why we have
on-site infection control teams taking
charge of the situation we had yesterday
891 people
according to the information we provide
in the update yesterday 891
hospitalized
positive for coven 19 yesterday in that
announcement our hospitalization
announcement the record the pre-omicron
record was in the 500s there were more
than
500 people in hospital in the fraser
health authority and so they are
managing that
led by infection control teams and and
uh doing a good job and it's a real
challenge though and
it has affected
healthcare systems as well there's
obviously for example
as i say
2325 employees with sick hours for in
fraser health uh from january 17th to
19th which is
um not an insignificant number more than
we would usually see by
probably a quarter uh 25
so that's a significant thing to manage
but
our infection control staff are doing a
good job but when you have a lot of
people in the hospital you have to
manage within the space you have and
and ensure that inspection control
stays high and that's what our teams are
doing in hospitals across bc
lisa youth
hi there i'm wondering um and i think
probably a few dr henry maybe minister
dix regarding the testing so the basics
are
if you are vaccinated and not in one of
the uh
high-risk groups or working with a
high-risk group and you're over 18 you
pretty much cannot get a test
if your employer doesn't provide it or
if you're not part of some sort of
outbreak response is that accurate that
pretty much your only roots are through
work or
through some private measures if you are
over 18
and vaccinated and not one of the
high-risk groups
and you have mild illness yes so
it's a finite capacity for testing and
we need to reserve that for people who
where it will change their management or
their ability to to go to work for
example so that's the best use of
testing right now
and i think that's
that's one of the reasons why
you know there are many people who have
uh illness with mild illness right now
some of which is covet and we all just
need to take those measures to stay away
away from others and not pass it on to
others if we're feeling unwell
lisa do you have a follow-up
what is going to happen for people who
have i've stepped with log covet there's
many people concerned that if they don't
have this positive task
they're not going to have access to that
treatment
and then i guess sort of it goes a
little bit too if people ever need to
leave the country and they've tested
positive they're not going to test going
out which i know is you know less a
priority but what does this mean for
people who may need a positive test for
other steps particularly long cover
treatment down the road
yeah so we are working with the clinics
that we have around long covet and there
are other ways of determining if
somebody has been infected post-hoc so
we can do antibody testing it's not
widely available but it is a way of of
determining if somebody has had an
infection with covet 19. so that's not a
pre-prerequisite
um to getting treatment for ongoing
symptoms that may be related to covet at
all so i would not be concerned about
that and we are of course it's
particularly
we are seeing that there's less risk
and of course we're still collecting
data on that but if you're vaccinated
and have milder illness the risk of
developing long covet goes down quite
dramatically as well
at previous in in the delta wave we saw
that two doses of vaccine reduced the
risk of long covet if you did get
infected by over 50 percent and we have
no reason to think it would be any less
than that uh with omicron so
these are the the factors that we need
to think about in terms of travel
many countries are getting rid of that
uh
window that they are allowing people to
say i had a recent infection and i prove
it with a pcr test um so but you know
those are are
optional things for people and there are
private ways that they can get a pcr
test if it's required for travel but
it's not part of the publicly funded
system
next question is from lisa cordasco
vancouver son
thank you good morning um what direction
or guidance is being given to long-term
care homes about
visits
when they run out of rapid tests for
those essential visitors
yeah so
as we mentioned and i i don't think i
answered that directly but we are
updating the guidelines and working with
the sector
but really it's a triaging so yes if
they run out of rapid tests those
regular visitors who were tested
the day before
can be allowed in with a symptom
screening so we will not be denying
people those important visits because of
a lack of access of rapid tests we'll do
the symptom screening making sure that
we have uh that that people are
prioritized and making sure that we can
use the rapid test for the people that
we have more
who are newer visits and if there's none
at all then going back to what we have
been using all along which is the
screening for symptoms
follow-up lisa
yes thank you um
what is the plan for allocating more
rapid tests to long-term care homes
beyond the original 200 thousand that
was announced and we were told were
already deployed you know is there a
plan to allocate
you know what are the numbers for
allocating any rapid tests um in the
future to long-term care homes and also
as i understand that there there are no
actual specific allocations to assisted
living sites at the moment
yeah so both of those are being
addressed over to minister dicks
minister
we're receiving
we're receiving between now in the
middle of february 15 million rapid
tests rapid tests are being account
allocated to long-term care homes around
bc there's no real area of life or
health that has a higher
priority for us the testing sites and
acute care are equivalent priorities
than long-term care but i would expect
long-term care homes to
receive the rapid tests they need to
support visitations and to support
keeping their workers safe and keeping
their residents safe the challenge in
long-term care and you see it from the
numbers on hospitalizations is in
general
the people who are in long-term care are
over either over 80 or over at least
over 70 and have three or more
conditions if so if you look at the
chart you see that the risk is very high
for all those in long-term care and is
why
measures have been in place and continue
to put
be put in place keep people safe
including that everyone
requires a double vaccination to visit
requires
rapid testing and those rapid tests will
be available requires infection control
supports that have been put in place
thousands of people have been hired to
support those efforts so it's really
challenging right now because the
omnicron variant of concern is
everywhere as we've seen in bc with
these very high case counts and that
includes people who
work in long-term care and others who
are essential visitors so
we're going to continue to take strong
action to protect long-term care
there are many
where there's co-location of assisted
living and
the campus of care and long-term care
and and
rapid tests are available for those
settings and we as
more shipments come in assisted living
will have access as well next question
is from victor kaiser radio now
good morning dr henry and minister dix
uh i'm going to shift this a little bit
i've been following the story of course
about service reductions and interior
health i guess the questions for the
minister because of these uh omicron
staffing challenges
uh most notably in barrier but also
ashcroft clearwater and other places
like kamloops local mayors tell me they
were not told about the changes minister
and uh you know despite being in
meetings with interior health uh that
morning right when things were announced
they founded about it in a press release
in your mind is that acceptable and i
guess also is it acceptable for us to
close an entire health care facility
like barrier and redirect people to rih
which you've said yourself has been in
crisis for weeks and months
just to
understand
just to to understand
what happened interior health presented
its plan its
surge plan
on paper
at the time of the briefing
there was a meeting with interior health
mayors
that everyone was invited to
at three o'clock i believe that day
and a briefing was given by susan brown
the president ceo of
of interior health i was on the call and
dr henry was on the call
and as you know um because you cover
these issues there's been challenges
throughout the last month in clearwater
and ashcroft and the idea was to support
the emergency department by reducing
patient services to maintain stability
of care for for urgent emergent care and
that's what they're doing
and our plan and our intention is to
restore that care but we should
acknowledge the very high test
positivity interior health and the real
health care challenges there the
difference in some ways between interior
health and the metro vancouver health
authority is that even though
there are of course many many more
people in metro vancouver that the
facilities are physically closer
together and there's a greater ability
to support them that's been a challenge
in smaller towns but as we uh we're only
going to do this if we need to do it to
protect and support patient care in in
vermeer for example the plan had been to
do just that and it's been decided by
interior health they don't need to do
that and as the number of health care
workers the number of health care
workers off sick has actually reduced
this week including in interior health
against last week that situation will
get better but these are plans put in
place because of the necessities of the
omercon variant of concern it's interior
health acting proactively and they have
done to protect the healthcare system
there it's a very significant challenge
in interior health probably greater
right now than any of the other health
authorities and i think our teams are
doing a good job but no one wants to see
any service
even temporarily closed and that's why
it's our intention
and our ask is for everyone to follow
public health guidance and orders and
that we need to take these steps to
support the system and support uh
support care in the system and that's
what they're doing so i think uh i i
don't know with respect to the
complaints i'm happy to talk to the
mayors but i can tell you that
the information bulletin went out i
believe at at three o'clock the briefing
happened at three o'clock the press
conference happened i believe at 1 30.
and so
and questions and we answered questions
from mayors across interior health
between three and four and susan brown
who's our ceo in interior health has
been working day and night to support
communities and support services
in kamloops and everywhere else with
respect to barrier it is unfortunate but
the intention is to ensure that we bring
our staff together to provide the care
that's necessary
and it's our hope to reopen there as
soon as possible
vector
i guess go back to uh you know some of
the changes i guess in uh policies and
testing and what have you the message
has been stay home if you're sick right
you mean that's
i guess all fine and what have you but
uh what would people do if they only
have those five paid sick days you know
brought in by the government because i
know of a couple who've told me they've
used three or four such days here we are
now on january 21st and you know they've
got most of the years still to go and
they're worried that they're either
going to be forced back to work when
they need to stay home or if they choose
to stay home they're not getting paid
and then we know they have trouble
perhaps making rent and what have you so
uh
what what do people in that boat do when
they don't have those paid sick days and
they're running out
i think i'll defer to the minister
around them
i think i'll defer to the minister
around that go ahead minister well
victor you make the point that we do as
of january 1st have five paid sick days
in bc which is five more than
other canadian provincial jurisdictions
and that's important and that doesn't
mean it's easy or that that
when people get sick they don't face
real challenges but it's important that
we have those sick days in place now i
think people in bc overwhelmingly
support them they support public
health's efforts to manage the covet 19
pandemic and
yes it's a very it's a significant
challenge in many sectors obviously
people have
largely unionized sectors and others
people have a higher level of sick day
protection but
but five days is a significant
improvement and
and but this recognizes everybody
recognizes the challenges workers
workers face not just now not just in
the coven 19 pandemic but in general in
dealing with sickness it's why it's also
so important
that we keep public services open and
and why
the fact that bc has kept schools open
has been so helpful to families and to
children through throughout this
pandemic period and that hasn't been the
case everywhere else so
i recognize the challenge i empathize
with that that's why we put
province with our province-wide sick day
plan into place and this illustrates
the importance of that plan and you may
be making the case that there should be
more days
and i and i hear that that concern
that's been expressed by many
as well but five days is an excellent
start in protecting workers
we have time for one
good morning um and answers please both
in english and french the west vancouver
school district wants vaccine clinics
for children to be set up in schools uh
will you consider that in that district
and other districts given the relatively
low rate of vaccination in children 5 to
11 in bc
absolutely and i know
vancouver coastal is working with each
of the school districts every school as
are
the health authorities around the
province and in some
areas some schools in particular
it has been done and it will be done
again
but those are decisions made on a
school-by-school basis with the local
mho
go ahead minister
[Music]
just say the numbers are pretty
straightforward
bell we've uh we're approaching fifty
percent of all children five to eleven
who have received their first those
vaccinations some will be receiving
their second dose fairly soon in fact
and there's very significant variations
like vancouver coastal health
the health authority that west vancouver
is in has a relatively high rate of
immunization i think it's around 65
percent the northern health authority
for children 5 to 11 is much lower 30
percent in fact there's very little
difference between the health 30s and
the 70 and above category and pretty
wide differences between 5 and 11. what
you'll also see is that every year if
you go from 17 to 12 this is true from
11 to 5
that
that each younger cohort has a has a
lower um level of immunization the one
before it so we're going to take all
steps to try and increase
immunization across the system but as dr
henry said and we have a lot of
experience with this with those 12 to 17
now the most effective clinics for us
with children 5 to 11 and 12 to 17 have
been community clinics so far and often
when we've gone into schools it's led to
a somewhat slow response but also has
brought challenges to some of those
schools so we're uh
and not not fantastic results in terms
of immunization but we're learning every
day and there's going to be cases where
there's schools and certainly that's
true in places in in remote and rural
areas of bc
excuse me
remote in rural areas of bc where we're
doing all of community approaches and
those all of community approaches tend
to take place in the schools
felt you have a follow-up it's like
you're preparing british columbians for
the long haul you know how we're going
to live with covet 19 for the long term
that's pretty bleak news for those who
are clinically extremely vulnerable
what's your message to those people
today and english and french please yeah
so i i do think i don't think that this
is how we're going to live with it in
the long term but it is what we need to
do to get us through this part and it
tells us a couple of things one is
the importance of vaccination we've seen
that this booster dose makes a
tremendous difference even for those who
are clinically extremely vulnerable and
the people who are older age and you
know we we maintained that interval that
six-month interval because
we have ongoing evidence and increasing
evidence that that gives us
longer-lasting protection so that is
going to help for whatever comes next
because there will be something next um
i i do believe we're going to be living
with this virus what i hope and what
i've talked about before is you know
historically what we see is sort of
smaller and smaller oscillations
but it is a reality that people who
don't have a strong immune system
won't
will still be at risk of having some
more severe illness and we see that with
other respiratory viruses that cause
infections as well influenza being
classic and it is people who are older
people who have immune compromising
conditions and they're very young who
who tend to be most at risk and i expect
that that is likely to continue for some
time i hope
but you know i hope it's not a strategy
but i do hope that we will end up with
another coronavirus that causes mostly
mild illness but it may be
that people who are in that older age
group or people who are
have immune compromising conditions will
need to get periodic boosters and it may
be that most of us who've now had the
three doses
won't need to have periodic boosters so
those are the things that we don't yet
know
but those are possibilities that we need
to start thinking about now and it has
been trying to balance
the best protection that we can get for
the longer term and dealing with what
we're dealing with right now that has
led to the decisions that we've made
around many of the things that are
happening right now so in that sense you
are
right that we're preparing for how do we
live with this
when we no longer need to have those
restrictions that we have in place now
and i do think we will get through this
wave and because of the amount of of
transmission we've seen and
the amount of
immunity that we've developed from
vaccination and from the uh the
transmission of omicron that we're
probably going to have
a much more gentle summer um that we've
had for the last two summers so that
will be good and then we'll have to
prepare ourselves to whatever comes next
in the fall
over to you minister
all right you were just listening in
there on bc's latest coven 19 briefing
we bring in our legislative bureau chief
keith baldry who joins us from victoria
with some analysis now keith something
that stood out right away is that the
province is no longer relying on contact
tracing to prevent transmission that we
should all assume we've really come into
contact with someone who has it can you
expand on what dr henry said about
living with it and going back to basic
principles
yeah so we relied heavily on contact
tracing when we were only picking up you
know 400 500 700 cases a day because we
had fifteen hundred contract tracers i
think at the peak so they were able to
stay on top of the cases uh for the most
part uh by and large but now that we're
having two thousand three thousand in
some cases four thousand cases detected
a day uh just basically overwhelms the
contact tracing uh system and uh it's
it's strategic use so the assumption is
now omicron is so much more infectious
it's hitting so many more people that
the assumption is you probably know
someone or you've been in contact with
someone who's had the virus so finding
the virus right now is not as critical a
task as is ensuring that people most
vulnerable of the most severe outcomes
of getting the virus are protected and
that means ensuring that as many people
vaccinated as possible particularly
older people
and again this is that's the number one
layer of protection is vaccination the
charts she provided today shows that by
and large
unvaccinated people in particular over
the age of 70 run a real risk of going
into hospital and potentially the icu
and the percentages just speak again
it's all about age people over the age
of 70 are really the highest risk of
going into hospital and the risk of
really severe illness is really not
there for younger people who are
vaccinated so the use of contact tracing
uh back when we didn't have a lot of
people vaccinated was you was sort of
greater than it is now to pick up
whether or not the virus was in a 40
year old for example or a 30 year old
that's not as critically important now
as it is ensuring that people who are
most vulnerable don't go into hospital
keith a huge focus as you said on
hospitals today looking at the bigger
picture how are our hospitals faring
given the recent increase in covid cases
yeah it's very interesting so the
hospitalization rate is actually lower
and it
takes a while to figure this one out
than the fault but in the fall we didn't
have as many positive cases so the
percentage of people in hospital was
actually higher compared to the all the
positive cases than it is now when we've
got so much more positive cases even
though the number of people in hospital
right now is greater than the fall the
percentage of positive cases is actually
lower so on the one hand uh it's putting
people in hospital in greater numbers
but it's not causing a bed shortage as
of yet emily but what it is a concern
and i think one of the questions
addressed this is we do and adrian has
provided an update on how many
healthcare workers are sick right now
the number is dropping which is
encouraging but it's still almost double
what it usually is and that has a big
impact on the providing care in a
hospital that now
yesterday for example i think 158 people
went into hospital 162 people came out
but this still means a lot of activity
in terms of testing people in hospitals
so it's it hasn't overwhelmed the system
but it's certainly creating pressure
like we have not seen before
i wanted to touch on something again
related to hospitals we learned of new
information that a fraser health may no
longer be able to separate those who are
covet positive from other patients who
don't have the virus but are fully
vaccinated so what is
exactly the reason for this
basically a crunch of space and people
so so many more people are going into
royal columbia and surrey memorial right
now about half the cases every day are
in fraser health half the
hospitalizations so we're having more
than 100 hospitalizations a day that's
50 or so people that are being
hospitalized in some of these large
hospitals in fraser health and so the
number of people going in is significant
and literally anybody who's been into
royal columbia or one of these hospitals
knows there's only so much space in
wards it was easier to separate people
when we had fewer patients in there but
yesterday 891 patients with covet uh our
previous peak was back in april at 500
end of april april 28th 515 people so
we're almost doubling that in terms of
size so literally running out of
physical space
in the fraser uh health hospitals and
that's why it's again it's not across
the board not everyone is going in not
all positive cases are going to be with
all negative cases if people have
respiratory
ailments they are going still going to
be separated you can still have
different forms of omicron and different
symptoms so it's not a uniform system
but it does mean in some cases uh people
who test positive with uh with omicron
will be in the same ward as people who
test negative it's just again it comes
down to physical space or lack of
just want to switch to gears a bit here
you have some new stats i understand
keith the vaccine rates among kids and
it does seem some regions in particular
are struggling to get their numbers up
yeah this came up at the very end of the
briefing today so the vaccination rate
for five to 11 year olds uh is really
been a bit of a grind it's nowhere
proceeding nowhere near as quick as we
saw with with older groups so right now
the province-wide average is 48 percent
of the 350 000 kids in that age group
have got their first dose but as you
mentioned emily does vary from region
region it's a high of
63 percent in vancouver coastal which
again had the highest and
vaccination rate amongst adults in terms
of outpacing other regions but it's down
to a low of just 30 percent in northern
health and that northern health number
really hasn't changed much at all it was
24 a month ago now it's 30 percent
others 39 in the interior 45 in fraser
56 over here on vancouver island 63 in
vancouver coastal so you're going to
hear i think a little more perhaps some
advertising and public health messaging
to encourage parents to get their kids
vaccinated in this age cohort because
it's really been a slow grind and the
pace is just not what public health
officials have been hoping for all right
get vaccinated it's always been the key
message as always keith thank you for
your analysis and your expertise on this
okay
well stay with us we'll have more coming
up after the break